let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0
4750 let's talk to our caller from the
804 area code who's this where you're
calling from
hello yes that's you who's this okay
Cathy okay it's not so much a question
that I have to ask you but it's just an
observation okay
a while back when this all started
everything was so uncomfortable I have
quite a few Republican friends yeah
and they started act real strange and
these weren't just acquaintances we've
gone on vacation everything and here
lately it's like they're cracking okay
let's see if I make can I ask just a
couple questions so that I know when you
say when this all started what do you
mean well what I mean is when well
number one I never identified that they
were for Trump in the first place
because I'm never getting to something
really interesting but what I what I
just want to know when you said when
this all started do you mean when Trump
started when Trump first came out to go
for president yeah okay got it got it
when so I'm sorry playing the candidate
Cassie hold on please
I think I can help I never expressed any
of that who didn't express what Cassie
the friend they didn't express what that
they support Trump they didn't express
that they supported Trump okay how do
you know that they're beginning how do
you know that they do well it was never
it's a certain talk they do okay there's
a certain type of talk oh his nom
his nomination started yep then all of a
sudden we need a businessman for
practice right and it just came out of
the blue we had just came from the beach
for a week and I was like what this I
was just shocked I was like - that I
know that I know that rhetoric okay I've
heard it before right I'm here on the
job really yeah I heard it
look let me tell you something Oh David
please let me tell you something this
talk started way back this is nothing
new
which talks no meeting a businessman for
president no this this talk that the
Republicans are doing what are they
saying this this started with I'm much
much older than you
that's okay I don't know no I'm not
apologizing I'm saying to you when I'm
maybe I'm not getting there cause what
I'm trying this is let's just break it
down I'm trying to say is that when they
started out so strong yeah
in the Trump crap I'll put it that way
they were steadfast your friends yeah
okay it was like they turned into these
people we're two different races but it
never who's two different races you and
Trump we would hire you in her friends
the Trump voters because my friends are
tumblers are all white okay I'm African
American
gotcha and we've been friends over 15
years that's how long it went back in 15
years of going on vacation and doing
everything together yeah there was never
anything mm-hmm
dude they are they often on drugs during
vacations on what do they take any drugs
during vacation no okay no dear they
don't well so that's not the explanation
that I think we can say
my point is this yeah my point because I
I think we're getting lost in the
translation because my translation is
getting lost what I'm trying to say is
his whole orange and these are educated
people sure we all went to college
master's degree all this and these
aren't dumb people okay academic wise
book smart they and they're not clueless
to different races they're aware of race
but say they're guys they're aware of
race yes they're aware of everything had
been around kind of people we are
everywhere here they're everywhere but
she sparked a fear yep absolutely Cassie
I couldn't have said it better myself
really appreciate the call I do have to
move on and I do I do hope to spend
again very very interesting and listen
these are issues that everybody's
dealing with I don't know I don't know
how us to say it but I totally
understand what she's referring to